hey what's up guys and welcome today I'm
going to be getting a battery tips video
series so if you haven't subscribed
already you might want to do so sorry if
this is choppy at all I'm using my
webcam for these first few videos so I'm
going to be starting a battery tips
tutorial I have a laptop so I I'm
obviously getting a lot of experience
with the battery this is the battery
this is the 8 cell battery to the HP
Pavilion dv6 oh the 12-cell battery is
in it right now
but the first tip I'm going to share
with you guys for the bad for conceived
conserving battery is to defragment your
hard drive I'm gonna have to pull up
later in an obviously a later video how
you guys can get a defragmenting tool
called called um grab diskeeper okay
it's called diskeeper and basically what
it allows you to do is defragment your
hard drive more often and basically why
you want to defrag your hard drive is
because the more windows has to go in
and look for things in a hard drive the
more the hard drive is spinning and more
it's using battery and hard drives need
a lot of batteries are spinning the 7200
rpm hard drive so that's going to drain
a lot of battery so the less it has to
look around your hard drive the less
you'll be using your hard drive if you
think about it so if you don't have a
lot of RAM and you have a you find
yourself accessing your hard drive quite
a bit then defragging your hard drive
about once a week is a very good idea
for UI defrag like every other day just
cuz I'm I'm I have a defrag tool like
diskeeper so that's my number one tip
this is episode one of the battery saver
tips series I hope you enjoyed this
video and please be sure to check out my
video on how to get diskeeper 2008 so
thanks for watching guys peace